THAT'S THE, UH--OKAY, YOU GOT
THE MOST SPACE FOR ATTACHMENTS.
ANYWAY...
- THANK YOU.
- FEEL FREE TO HIT ME UP
IF YOU REMEMBER THAT NUMBER.
I NOTICED YOU AIN'T
WRITE THAT DOWN.
DAMN, DAMN, DAMN.
THAT GIRL WAS FLY, RIGHT?
- [scoffs] SHE ALL RIGHT.
BUT DID YOU SEE
THAT LIAM NEESONS MOVIE
WITH THEM WOLVES, THOUGH?
- THE ONE WITH THEM BIG-ASS
WOLVES AND LIAM NEESONS IN IT?
- MAN, LIAM NEESONS
IS MY [bleep]!
- OH, LIAM NEESONS STRAIGHT
JACKED UP THEM WOLVES, MAN.
- MAN, HE [bleep]
THEM WOLVES UP, MAN.
- YEAH.
- SHOOT, MAN.
HEY, AND DON'T EVEN GET ME
STARTED ON THAT ONE
WHERE THEY TOOK
HIS DAUGHTER.
- [scoffs] "STRAIGHT TOOKEN,"
STARRING LIAM NEESONS!
- MAN, LIAM NEESONS
ON THE PHONE LIKE,
"I HAVE A CERTAIN
SET OF SKILLS."
MAN, DON'T [bleep]
WITH LIAM NEESONS!
- NO, DON'T EVEN TRY AND
BE RUSSIAN AROUND LIAM NEESONS.
HE'LL TAKE YOUR ARM AND...
- [screams]
- PUT SOME FRACTURES UP IN THAT.
- THEY KILLING HIM, MAN.
AND THEN--OH, YOU SEE
THE SECOND ONE, THOUGH?
IN THE SECOND ONE,
THE RUSSIANS COME AFTER HIM
AND HE [bleep] THEM
ALL UP ANYWAY.
- "TAKEN 2," STARRING
THE INCOMPARABLE LIAM NEESONS.
- MM-HM. MM-HM.
- THAT'S MY [bleep].
- WHAT ABOUT DARKMAN, THOUGH?
- NO.
- WHAT ABOUT LIAM NEESONS
IN SOME DARKMAN, THOUGH?
WHAT ABOUT DARKMAN, THOUGH?
- WHEN LIAM NEESONS' FACE
WAS CHANGING UP, MAN?
- HOMIE WAS STRAIGHT
FACE-CHANGING.
NOW THAT'S JUST LIAM NEESONS
ACTING RIGHT THERE, MAN.
- STRAIGHT UP, I KID YOU NOT.
ACADEMY-AWARD CALIBER.
CLASSIC NEESONS.
- MAN, COME ON, SERIOUSLY.
I MEAN, LIKE, NEESONS
ALREADY NEED TO HAVE A STATUE.
- LIAM NEESONS AIN'T GOT NO--
- HE AIN'T GOT NO STATUE.
- HE--
- HE AIN'T GOT A STATUE.
HE AIN'T GOT A STATUE.
- NO. NO. NO. NO.
THE OSCAR GOES
TO LIAM NEESONS, DARKMAN.
[bleep] FACE WAS CHANGING!
- MM-HM. WORD.
- HOW HARD IS THAT?
- IT AIN'T HARD.
IT'S NOT HARD AT ALL.
- DAMN!
- IT'S STUPID.
- OH! OH! BATTLESHIP.
- OOOH!
- BATTLESHIP.
- BATTLESHIP!
- OOOOH!
OOOOH!
- BATTLESHIP!
- OOOOH! WHOO!
- LIAM NEESONS STRAIGHT
KILLED A ROBOT BOAT!
- LIAM NEESONS IS MY SHIZNIT!
- WHOO!
- BUT YOU KNOW WHO I LIKE
AS MUCH AS NEESONS, THOUGH?
- [scoffs] AS MUCH AS NEESONS?
- MM-HM.
- WHO?
- BRUCE WILLY.
- [screams]
[screaming continues]
BRUCE WILLY IS MY SHIT!
- BUT WHAT IF
THEY MADE A MOVIE
WITH LIAM NEESONS
AND BRUCE WILLY?
[grunting]
- NEESONS AND WILLY?
- WILLY AND NEESONS.
- HARDER MAN. HARDER!
- [grunting]
- [choking]
THAT WOULD BE...
both: MY [bleep]!
[boom]